okay for people joining this livestream
we are looking at functions that have
been tagged as experimental emotion
language which we are considering their
future and how they should be promoted
or developed in future versions starting
off oh boy
look entity function is part of the
whole giant gaggle I mean okay
does Michael want to comment on this how
happy is Michael with this I have used
it I haven't you said you much to make a
final comment I guess it's also much
more important for the database side
than for the built-in knowledgebase you
know I mean it's like
I'm not entire don't entirely agree with
this statement because I think that
entity function behaves like a like an
entity property and this is really
important and as such even when applied
on built-in and these are antsy classes
it has a different for example we're not
even defining here is an exception since
the fall parameter I mean come on guys
you know this is a giant you know it's a
giant thing where we're putting
beautiful wrapping paper around some
pretty ugly external stuff yeah sure but
even when you are not dealing with well
okay so what can I do efficiently with
internal stuff so for example let's
imagine that I want to get okay so let's
get not how efficient it is internally
the point it has it has different
semantics than function so if you apply
if that's a perfectly small number of
examples and where's the third argument
example I thought that there was a how
do I get the mean weight of all
satellites okay so if I say I didn't it
was well if I say this and I say
satellite here and I say entity function
of you know that is gonna map that's why
it's not the same
antics okay fine so so what do you want
me to do an aggregated entity value
class a great history class
yeah right and then comma mass goes to
total this is a shorthand I will mean
whatever you want to do okay is that it
hey and then opens no open calls mouth
is that smoke
that's the a symbolic but what you want
to do open close what mass you have to
extract a property out of this this is
just a no no not there not there
remove one yeah come on oh I'm too close
after mean close and then open again
that's property extraction that's forty
four thousand things there what's it
doing Tony
downloading first all the satellites
then in chunks of 500s the masses of
each one and then aggregating so that's
not done on the server no why not I mean
could it be
hot potentially but not in the sense of
translator to a database or maybe in
some cases yes this was the big splat
right Stephen if you're using 12.1 that
is a known bug
I would suggest either going to 12 oh it
should work in 12 oh okay
yeah I mean there is a known bug
reported about that
by the way you saw my report yesterday
about satellites where I was saying um
but you were trained you were speaking
about time dependent for these I agree
masker become dependent as well but I
don't think we tag it as such
okay what is it doing any idea any
itself somehow I mean when you say this
is a very nice wrapping paper around
external stuff if you do this 100
gigabyte table on postgrads it takes
three seconds yeah well so something is
wrong here so this wasn't a bug specific
to twelve one yes I are sixty do you
know what it is I can imagine from the
messages yes okay now it will be
interesting to know I mean again the
examples here are utterly inadequate
given the amount of detail in here the
examples are just utterly inadequate
right where are the examples of external
databases here I don't see them
right we obviously need to show that I
guess I'll add them anyway my general
point with respect to all the new entity
class functions like aggregated combined
filtered etcetera is that they don't
have any evaluation semantics and so
that to me that makes it pretty clear
that we're not we're not gonna I mean we
might add the extra arguments and stuff
like that but since they stay and
evaluated and they they just informed
you know and the way entity value works
I think it's fairly uncontroversial that
they are not going to change as they're
just there's moloch representation
something well unless it's the wrong
symbolic representation yeah but III
think that if we decide that something
is the wrong Samoyed representation we
might as well change the name entirely
rather than making backward incredible
changes why you would eventually store
experimental I mean this to me is a is a
is a fairly you know this is working I
don't I don't agree I mean I I think
that as soon as we start we'll get more
serious about writing this stuff we will
realize that the fact that we have mixed
data and metadata in the first argument
only for in-memory entity stores and
then for relational databases you only
keep the metadata in the first argument
and that is cool that's completely
different things if you changed I
understand well if you want to make a
proposal make it now okay my proposal is
that this stuff like for example in the
first example you see P 117 P 259 etc I
would really like that to evaluate to a
two-word version where the values of the
properties are stored in the second
argument and you only keep metadata
first I don't think that's obviously
stupid Tony what do you think about that
data in the store is pretty symmetric we
could do that but I understand your
comment so we always had this discussion
between metadata and not metadata and I
think we can make the split but I don't
see it's necessary I have a little bit
of reservations well in a certain
abstract sense I agree with the point
but in a practical sense when I develop
an entity store I frequently do it
iteratively and once I have to evaluate
that form it's no longer so nice to edit
and to protest manually
look the way we can get the best of both
worlds is to allow both syntaxes yes but
once we it's not the issue of allowing
both Syntel if you have one and you want
to edit this one it's in the form form
of the evaluation I see it so you guys
actually positively like the single
argument mixed data and metadata form
that exists an entity store right now I
think it's a philosophical issue what is
metadata yeah sure but on the other
right and so some relational databases
have a particular model which isn't the
one we're gonna use but on the other
hand suppose you want to like if you
think about data set for example like
how do you go from anti stored for data
set in theory you could do just if I had
that sorry why isn't that a link there
what when it's a link everywhere else
here why is that that seems to be a bug
in the documentation processor I'll find
it then okay go ahead so what I was
saying is that if you if you look at the
way data set works you can always say
like normal data set and just get the
data
well data set has a lot of extra
information that you don't see about the
types and so on it's only in theory you
could do something like last Valente
store and then apply data set to that
and that's just the data and then it
gets processed with the data set well I
I don't buy that I'm sorry
the having you know having data set each
entity store that makes perfect sense
having it be something where you can
like go part seven of data of entities
store things into a data set it's not
sensible yeah sure that's I was not
proposing that that's the syntax what
I'm saying is that conceptually if you
wanna turn an empty store into a data
set that's what you would do and that
gives you a clear split between what is
data and what is nice data
I understand but so we can have a way
that if you feed entity store into a
data set if you say data set of entities
store what does it do right now does it
do anything
Tony or anybody so the right-hand side
where you see type goes to that one can
be a data set it basically strips the
data set
you
what the heck is that no that's oh that
didn't work I understand where it says
type goes to data III that I'm aware of
I know that that can be a data set but
what I'm asking is well the data set of
an entity store works and seems to me it
should work well it does but what
exactly do you expect I expect it to
take the non metadata part of the data
set and use it but that might bring
under the situation that you have
entities there unless you want just the
bare strings that have not been
registered yet
hold on hold on let's think about that
so that's a foreign key I mean that's
the same as you you have in databases
and so on so but the the question of how
you extract okay so if I were to take
this entity store and I just want the
data set piece of the entity store how
would I do that so you're saying that
even so well can't we have a symbolic
representation of the unregistered
entity
I see it has to refer to at entity store
to its parent entity store and there's
no way to do that purely symbolically
without actually in training the
entities store yep so one thing that you
could do is register the store and say
anything of type comma data set that
might give you what you want but sooner
I think that this question of the
foreign keys is is a little bit deeper
than that algebra key because the
question is really right now data set is
designed to store hierarchical data and
so there is no way to represent loops
and entities and sorry entity value
properties are links that are
potentially loops here huh and so on
your point you could you could eagerly
expand its each entity to its values but
that might be infinite because the the
graph is not going to be a psychic but
that's the later understand if if the
right hand side can be an entity then
that's perfectly representable in a data
set lazy
yes not lazily just sits there as an
entity it's not the value of the entity
yeah it's easy in the sense no the value
that the right hand side of the thing in
this Association is an entity so there's
no loop there's a loop if you were to
try to follow everything and to compute
things from exactly and these represent
links in this in this graph and so if
you were to eagerly expand the graph and
you have like but there's we don't have
a function that does that what would do
that I mean we could say entity value
but that's not going to go you know
climbing through all of the sequence of
links so I don't think there's nothing
to discuss the point is that we if you
want to represent relational databases
with data sets faithfully then that's
problem you can't do it exact already
know that you can't do it so why are you
trying
it's a wrong thing to try to do
different purposes okay so by the way a
suggestion on the live stream from Brian
Harris that there should be an example
in entity store which seems to have a
rather anemic collection of examples
I should reduce him to have a list of
get the list of entities of the
specified type reduce him to have an
example of how to do that that's how you
discover the entities within the entity
store
um
okay so I mean the only suggestion here
if I take a typical entity store you
know in the function repository posit or
e rather there are um there are things
which are um entity stores happily um
and like we could take a random entity
store
I don't know what we want to do
whatever let's take that one I might
even understand okay all right so this
is an entity store
and
and now the question is is there a
corresponding data set to be extracted
from this right
they entered a list of
it's really weird the type is called
game of life that's an arguably not very
sensible thing and why is that oh
because I didn't say register but if I
said entity list is their way of doing
that without registering Tony no
document that way
why wouldn't entity list why wouldn't
you be able to put the entity's drawer
in place of the entity type name and
then you still can have multiple types
okay so maybe we need a syntax for
dealing with that yeah brilliant why is
there not wise enough the word and
you're not register random string why is
it them
yeah that's a failure it should have
given a message how do I register it I
say entry register of the entries of the
entry store right oh yeah
you
you
already exist so it was very confused
there how did it manage to why did it
let me register the plain string sir I'm
asking yes so so I try to make that
system as general as possible so
eventually we can register any kind of
object that behaves like an entity's
okay types already exist so I just did
entity unregister why did that not work
but Tony at the very least maybe you
could say yeah yeah like yeah I agree
with your idea that you could in theory
register a function that behaves like an
anti store but very least when you do
entity register it should query that
function for the types that it contains
and a string would yes that's exactly
what it does so I'm a little bit
surprised but yeah right Brian on a live
stream is suggesting that we have a
better inspector for entity stores and
why can't we use the same kind of
mechanism that we have for inspecting
relational databases
yes that's already in opens or Chesson
for that also for a new logo or icon
okay but but but that's all very well
and good but what's happening with it
I can increase the priority well what is
it that you're planning to build
basically using yeah the thing using the
same structure yeah well what is it for
the database back what is the structure
because that structure is specific to
two dimensional relational databases
which is different from entity stores
well maybe it isn't
yeah okay there understand what this
should have done right so what what
we've got here and I don't know why this
goofed up right I mean I you know I'm
sure if I quit here and restart why do
we have in the autocomplete menu why on
earth do we have those things that come
from those contexts we just shouldn't do
that see what I'm saying I don't know
okay
so now here if I say resource data of
this
okay and ste register of that now
okay and now I say enter this game of
life
now I'll get all kinds of entities there
okay so now each of those entities has
certain properties how do I discover
what the shape of the thing is do you
understand what I'm saying I mean I
suppose some of that information is in
here right
you could take an entity and say dataset
to get an idea
could say entity properties yes okay
okay but so now let's imagine that I
wanted to make a dataset out of that
entity store I guess that's pretty
straightforward isn't it I mean if I if
I just say for example if I were to say
I mean I could make a dataset by saying
entity value let's just see if I can see
how to do this game of life and then if
I say here let's say what's thing
date let's do date and let's do does it
have a size here and nobody a size
why these aren't an alphabetical order
by by string name I have no idea but um
let's say period
okay so the claim is donated are cool
asaurus so for example I should be able
to do something where I say date list
clot so that that did the right thing if
I'm not mistaken
oh for goodness sake what is wrong with
that
is that not treating miss incorrectly
rather I just delete missing do the
right thing here and delete all the now
it doesn't to give you to leave a level
spec in this case yeah but but does it
delete the whole object at that level
there is a way to do that but it's not
that's not what we want to level end to
be missing if missing occurs and by the
way the typesetting here is wrong
Raj please report that that that is the
wrong font size here
yes um okay so it's comma 2 comma 1 so
we'll be delete missing of that comma 2
comma 1 no that's wrong
- comma - oh it's just wrong it should
delete the whole element in this case
right did you see what I'm saying
that appeared to be right okay so let's
say I say for example dateless plot of
this okay
so this isn't completely grotesque what
we have to do here um okay uh I mean
this is wrong
by the way Raj that needs to be reported
right that should just have missing you
know that just shouldn't plot stuff
right okay I'll file the release
yes okay so now okay
looping back to all of this stuff okay
I'm actually very happy with entity
store and I think come you know I would
like to do experimental eyes I'm not
happy with entity function and I'm not
happy with that grid identity class I
don't think they've been used enough for
anybody to know anything and the fact
that they have giant documentation a few
examples isn't encouraging um on the
other hand you in the discussion we had
like last week about entity store or
still adding stuff to it and like what
like types for properties sure but I
think the basic operation of entity
store is not going to change
I mean we're adding sure we're adding
stuff we're adding plenty of functions
we've added to for 25 years I just don't
think we're going to change the
structure of entity stores I think it's
a well used well working thing I see one
addition to that this cluster is Tony in
some non-trivial examples you want an
initialization option where you also
define a bunch of functions because you
might have non-trivial computed
properties that don't all trust 10
characters that are 20 pages on there
okay fine you're not describing
something which which you know shoots
down the existing design you're just no
no no no I'm just saying that there are
none
right that sounds nice I mean I think I
mean I think that what we are seeing and
we'll hopefully understand this better
as we increase the automation of things
that we do with database is you know all
of these lower level functions which I
think are the basically the machine code
of dealing with databases will you know
um we have an example here um this is an
example from
I do not pronounce this let's call it I
see on our livestream because I don't
know how to say oops I went wrong there
I missed the bracket okay so this is an
example offered
and to the function and to the property
male population so that entity property
is necessary right it could have just
been quotes male population is that
correct guys yes yes
non-missing entity association that's
the return type of the I see that's the
entity values return type and then this
is plotting it that's pretty cool
actually it's a bit of a scary plot but
it's pretty cool why is Iceland sorry
I'm just looking at the actual um
well okay fine fascinating
um okay it's an interesting plus as well
as being there that's a pretty good
pretty good example that works quite
nicely now
yeah the alternative would be to map a
pure you know hash a male population -
female population over to do an
association map over the list of
countries right yeah but I mean and this
is currently I would consider it a bug
in the entity framework but if you
subtract two properties and they're both
missing that's zero and I think at least
until function should have the semantics
I'm saying if you are subtracting two
missings
if at least one of the properties you're
extracting is missing then the whole
thing is missing
look the factors that missing needs more
somebody yeah but okay it needs to be in
the relation semantics of missing it
cannot be in the evaluation demanding of
entity forms
yes I agree and I think as a matter of
fact that this is a good example both
the things we just saw about missing
interacting with dateless plot this is
something that should be we should
probably have an LCC item about missing
and about the possibility of getting
missing arithmetic to work but I think
missing - meaning is undefined
why isn't it missing
I think missing - missing should be
missing maybe I think admitting
obligation I feel like it's undefined
it's not missing what is missing saying
you missing equal missing well no I
think what it should do is it should
have a missing with something which says
that it is the result of our arithmetic
on a missing because missing has a
payload and it can describe the fact
that it is missing for that reason I
mean there's different reasons things
are missing
you know there's what's the melting
point of helium or something missing you
know doesn't physically exist STP or at
standard pressure whatever um but yeah
but what color trust aid like assume you
do comparison you also don't want equal
to immolate to true for two missing
things
I that's listen let's have a discussing
about missing I think missing needs to
may need to have some kind of new UID
thing inside it for exactly that reason
can we please get that scheduled as part
of an LCC meeting one already at some
point well what happened with it I don't
think we ever finished properly when the
little said the question of what is a
failure and what is missing what's up
because okay there's another let's get
the notes and let's make sure we move it
forward I mean now that we have a round
working which is very beautiful I think
this is kind of the next step
all right let's take a look at graph
store
so what do we know about I mean the one
of the use cases for this is
on earth is list these are these are
import formats right
yes
and as the one famously says it's
Turtles all the way down so to speak um
okay but so this is what is the
underlying support for wiki data data
for instance is that correct yes
I mean this stuff is in a package anyway
right is it in a package and tagged as
experimental yes boss
okay so there have been some small
improvements that didn't make it into
the first release and I also added some
new functionality and thanks to Rock'em
liquidator there were some slight
improvements so I'm not sure if you want
to review that in a extra session I
don't know it depends on how much there
is there but my question is other than a
wiki dated data case what are the uses I
mean I know some outside users we happen
to know have made good use of this
sparkle stuff do we know other
categories of users here
some intramural users I know if Aaron
who has been using that functionality
and now then ask me more things so that
was very good feedback um okay okay well
I don't
more to discuss with this I think it
seems like the graph store stuff it's
working okay but there's you know we're
right now in a phase where we're
watching the sort of usage grow
um
so to summarize keep an experimental
tool the usage increases I think though
until we understand more about what
people are doing with it um by the way
Brian our live stream asks a question
which is utterly irrelevant to this
meeting but I wonder about this - he's
asking wires and touch scrolling
supported under windows
I haven't a clue I don't think anybody
in this meeting knows but it's a good
question and perhaps some Raj could take
that on to the UI folk yep I'll pass it
along um
okay have we unexposed anything in this
database system
explore alized any of the functions here
you know I mean I I voted for the
experiment I mean most of America but
has it happened has anything been the
experimentalist in this whole collection
well you think to be against and the
only thing I'm not entirely sure about
the experiment ideas for tonight the
class given what we're doing with sort
my and the order that's somewhere I
think that this we should let usage grow
on these things a bit okay I mean I
think that they're I think it's a pretty
complicated subsystem and I think yeah I
mean hopefully yes
that brings us to ask I personally like
ask I don't know why I haven't heard of
more uses of it perhaps we can discuss
that I mean in other words you know I
think hey somebody's typing without
being on mute could you change that the
UM
why do we think it hasn't had more usage
I mean in a sense form function has had
put I mean for example do you know if
there are many ask functions running
within our own company supporting web
forms not many I mean my idea of what
you actually know I mean because I don't
know given the amount of feedback I
receive on on form function that's
that's how I get that number like for
every twenty function again on our own
form function I get one on ask and then
usually people tend to give up after a
while after a couple questions so why do
they give up what what is it my idea my
idea is that basically ask would really
like to work with something which is
like a core team so actually
interrupting the real Colonel state and
then going back to it but that doesn't
work with the way the cloud works right
now you can't freeze a kernel waiting
for people to answer and your you can't
be sure you get back to the same kernel
and so on so okay so you're saying that
that the statelessness the fact that the
state information is all carried inside
the ask function and so on usually
that's inconvenient to people yes
exactly
I don't know whether we have evidence of
that I mean I people are getting
confused about how to carry enough state
or what
yeah and and there's like there's always
some implicit states
suppose you have like some some random
function that's that's that's gonna lead
to some weird behavior and ask okay so
you know your point is that a stateless
non session based ask
I mean one could imagine a version of
ask that operates against a session
even though it's now we talked about it
with Dion at some point in you and and
and we were saying that maybe does make
sense to have some kind of special so
maybe is some that that that are
actually running against session
criminals instead of public Colonels but
then nothing well okay so that's
interesting I mean I don't think that's
on the card roadmap I mean what what is
on the cloud roadmap and which i think
is now done is in the persistence
location stuff being able to store stuff
in a web session right
yeah that's doable but that's not the
same as keeping the same kernel I
understand but I'm asking the web
session is okay my question is is that
now supported is web session is that
what yeah okay so there's a there's a
two-fold answer to this one is that I
had initially imagined to use cookies
rather than web sessions which are
similar but not quite the same and
cookies are not yet supported secondly I
can emulate that by using a couple of
tricks I don't really need to use a web
session to save the state of ask so what
was the thing that we had waited for
four months for web session to work I
don't know but I mean I think in general
the main problem with ask is that the
only person who knows how it works is me
project no but I'm sorry this isn't
answering the question why I mean maybe
that use case of people doing
back-and-forth conversation which is
what asked you know it's it's it's a
complex form filling function basically
mm-hm and maybe the tail of the
distribution of people with forms to
fill most people have simple forms to
fill and I mean I think that the
future of very complex form-filling is
form notebooks
you know we already have a technology
that supports all kinds of rich entry of
stuff and multiple items and setter
etcetera etcetera um but III think that
solves kind of an orthogonal problem in
that the question is like if you have a
four notebook
that's like a big one-page form that is
very rich in terms of input but it's not
very rich in terms of of interactivity
of going back and forth that's correct
but the the problem is you know it's
like the examples have asked I mean like
for instance okay I don't know whether
we've used it like for the summer school
for the application process for the
summer school do you know or is it just
a form oh it's just a form because it
doesn't really required to go back and
stuff like that right because it has no
contingency I mean that is let's imagine
that you are I don't know financial aid
for the summer school for example one
could imagine that there are many
branches there
oh if you're from outside the US do this
oh if you're from whatever do this and
that could be represented as an ask
function probably quite nicely is that a
true statement yeah except that in
general you know you have to reload the
page every time you go forward so you
know in the end it's easier to represent
it as like an interactive form that has
feel but yet hidden stuff like that on
the other hand the thing that you really
cannot do in any other way than ask it's
driving in fluid form so give me another
exercise give me another exercise and so
on that's impossible you can't keep in
pink yeah I understand thank you
relatively easy to do fair enough but so
the fact is that what we are now
imagining in terms of the give me
another exercise thing we aren't
interesting actually
I mean we're imagining that that whole
thing is done with form notebooks not
with this mechanism although maybe
there's a merged mechanism there that
has both of those things in it I don't
know I mean cuz there's a there's a
certain amount of state information that
ask III I think the issue is that
there's a kind of a hole in the market
of of things which are more complicated
than forms I'm not sure anyway I
wouldn't beat yourself up too much about
the design of ask I think it's perfectly
good I think it's a question of whether
it so happens I think it's more a
question of the user patterns may
respond to things on this live stream
but I I would like to I mean reopen this
discussion with we had some really nice
ideas when we talked with you and yarn
about conversation page and conversation
API
yes infrastructure so maybe we should
yeah right I don't think that's on the
cloud roadmap right now and I think that
in terms of I mean the design might be
fine but in terms of Polish I and wash
can confirm or deny this ask still has
white elephant bugs Raj yep that is the
case I mean ask never let me look up the
exact number but I do remember that we
had run into several issues when we were
testing asked functionality I mean and
they're also meta issues like Shawn was
complaining that ask is particularly
difficult to test automatically so who
knows how many more her that we haven't
found yes well why can't we use it test
it with web execute write questions from
a live stream is it possible to get a
dated entity function
and trusting using the dated rapper
how do we
what is that exactly mean that means
that you're using the attribute the
dated attributes state attributes of an
entity property in the energy function
makes sense
can you have a think about that they are
stroking look inside the entity function
but not outside
inside as in this entity property could
be dated here
right but the entity property itself the
entry function itself the dated rapper
will not flow into the answer depends
adieu
it probably doesn't know how deep to
flow if the entity function is dated
which properties are correct can be
dated so I think that's the problem okay
Ethan is saying ingesting unstructured
text to get relationship tuples in a
graph
what is being asked for there
so you mean take the sentence the sky is
blue or something and be able to turn
that into a kind of symbolic
representation of that statement yes
well we actually have a bunch of things
going on in that direction although I
don't think we want to I'm not a great
believer in just making some random you
know I mean we could make a sort of
random probabilistically determined sort
of graph out of that I don't think
that's all I use for I think it's
amusing but not very useful um but it is
an interesting I mean we actually have
in the generalization of text cases
that's the thing that we are looking at
being able to do
I'd be worth it if it just put that on
the next machine learning agenda chess
talk about that um self supervisor
information entity relation extraction
well interesting I mean yeah that that's
what we're talking about here I mean we
do remarkably well now at entity
extraction um we do not do entity
relation extraction at this time
although that is a direction that we're
looking at you know fine textual answer
effectively is doing that but I agree
that it is expose Abal now it's actually
interesting I mean the question of how
would we best expose it what would be
the structure that we expose so in other
words given a piece of text we would say
basically this piece of text is
equivalent to the following you know you
can it you can basically extract a graph
store out of this piece of text is what
we're saying
yeah that's interesting we should talk
about that um okay we are running out of
time here and our next oh boy
you
you
speak of the devil of fine texture
answer so I actually think a lot more of
these can be the experimental eyes than
you are
then you're indicating here
really a lot more do we have that in
here Adina's is an honest face i it's
that this we ran out of time there's no
point in doing this right now if he's
here however we just ran out of time
so I think we're gonna do this another
time I was just saying that I think a
lot of these functions are much more
robust and could be experimental I stand
I'd like to hear the arguments for not
the experimental Ising them okay um and
I'm yeah okay let's start the next
meeting with this um but I think we have
to UM ah if anything there's a lot of
machine learning research on knowledge
ingestion and well aware and you know
things like fine textual answer are fine
state-of-the-art things and they're just
not as useful as you might hope um
suggestion was being made which is
actually not a bad one of being able to
have from something like you know it's a
merger of text cases and fine textual
answer of being able to return
essentially the symbolic extracted graph
store from a piece of text which
effectively we have but we're not
exposing that and the question is do we
have a way to expose it in other words
could we build actually yeah could we
build an entity store from a piece of
text if it says you know the weight of
the rhinoceros is 7.2 tons the weight of
the flee is you know fact extraction
yeah right but I mean being able to
essentially build a known structure like
an entity store from a piece of text is
an interesting idea because what we have
I mean if we if we do like like I don't
know what's a short Wikipedia article if
we say um let's say oh my gosh I don't
know what's a really obscure kind of
animal hey I'm a Quokka how about that
let's hope the article about Crocker's
is fairly short
um I should've actually what I see on
the rolling with we turn it into an ante
so rather than in a graph store is that
you're bringing a lot of assumptions
about the types of things that you have
in well I understand that but I mean so
is this gonna work should be it might
take a little while yeah yeah this has
probably got a lot of stuff in it I mean
this isn't absurdly long um there we go
okay
this is now extracting so it's got 149
pieces there
Wow what the heck is that
are not this again I think this said
what version of my user I think I'm
using 12:1 here I think this is the same
bug that we keep on seeing Raj oh let's
take a look
same thing same thing I reported every
few days the same thing ok
in any case alright so this is this is
saying this is I don't know what two
peoples is okay founder reserved land
I'm surprised it's cool that's
impressive
yeah it's impressive Western Australia
administer division rottnest island is
an island okay a lot of good stuff here
like Gilbert's Potter ooh well it seems
to be a species since it said it was
critically endangered other things could
be critically endangered I suppose in
the world okay so there's a lot of good
stuff here that it really did I tagged
correctly now what it didn't do is to
say that property blah blah blah of a
quokka is well the Crocker is known to
live for an average of 10 years so it
didn't say you know quokka it didn't
make an entity store which said quokka
lifespan because right now it's not
doing in fact that's it that's the thing
that's what it really needs to do is to
do the extraction of properties as well
as the extraction of entities here right
if it could do that then it could turn
that into an entity store that says
quokka lifespan 10 years right yeah then
definitely I mean that's that's a big
the entity extraction is a first step
for that which we already have and we
have good entity extraction yeah yeah I
mean which true as to improving but yeah
and but we don't have a lotta extraction
and we don't have the extraction of
named we don't have I mean
entity I mean properties not yeah it's
really about context
so I guess normally the first step is
further entity and then from and you try
to figure out you know I mean a bit warm
alpha style if we can figure out a
property related to this entity yeah
Ethan is saying could find textual
answer be extended look for new entities
that are not already known well new
entities where we can guess they see the
thing is if you say mister you know John
Smith or something but let me be more
obscure mister you know kwaka fish
there's a decent chance that that mister
is a clue that Crocker is a first name
and fish is a last name even though
that's a category of entities that are
is sort of infinite if I'm making sense
right so I mean right now we don't
usually have a marker for something
being with the entities we're
identifying a ones that plausibly could
be in our system correct as opposed to
like people's names where we don't have
the seven point six billion or whatever
it is names in there kick can ask quest
we have fine textual answers do we have
like symbolic to represent this question
like the second argument of fine text we
absolutely didn't in the end when you
say how tall is I don't draw to me
that's really entity and property just
misses the value so if you could have a
symbolic representation of I know but
that's not the thing is that most
if we have entity and property then if
we've done our job from a curation point
of view we probably have the value sure
but my point is suppose we George
Clooney is something that doesn't exist
in our system and height is something
that doesn't exist in our system you
like fine textual answer understands the
questions and extract it from the text
know whatever you put that entity and
property are just a symbolic standing
they don't have to map to something in
our system but they do if it's gonna be
useful I mean that's the look the fact
is the ultimate way to do this is the
whole symbolic discourse language
project which we're slowly working
towards but I think it'll be interesting
so I mean the problem is by the time we
know both the entity on the property we
probably know the value the thing that
is sort of interesting is parametrized
entities where there's a potentially
infinite class of entities where we know
the type of the entity but we don't know
which particular entity of that type it
is of which people companies things like
that are good examples
sure but I mean I think an equally
interesting question is like this text
contains this many grammatically valid
statements about things we actually
don't know what they are and it is
saying or how useful that is to know
that I mean I think that what people
need is look find textual answer is fine
and state-of-the-art and not very useful
because you can't trust
the I mean it is somewhat useful for
scanning I mean I'm sure it can get a
decent grade in one of those SAT essay
comprehension tests if that's our
criterion um but look I think the
interesting case which is the one worth
discussing is parametrized entity types
like people for instance where we know
what type it is and therefore we know
certain properties but we don't know
which instance of that entity type it is
we also it's it's even you know it's not
trivial to disambiguate them but that's
the case that I think will be
interesting for text cases for instance
a 10
yeah we know it's a person but wait a
person that we know where we actually
know about that person we simply know
that it is a person yeah and then we
could do some interesting extraction
kinds of things anyway for a different
meeting but interesting topic and I need
to run off here um well thanks guys to
be continued um and thank you to people
on livestream interesting comments and
questions and look forward to hearing
from you all soon see you later
thank you